[Music]
almost a full minute of reading
goddamnit in a Tarzan movie in case you
confused it with the North American
Congo this white guy invading Africa war
white suit to further emphasize his
whiteness but he's carrying a Catholic
rosary type necklace thing so clearly
he's a good guy
I think unless he's a priest wait what
did I say that I don't think I did
trotty shop shouting that you are ready
so your enemy knows your status in
position one spear comes out of the fog
they fire and seconds later dozens of
natives can be seen lying on the rocks
when my point is goddamn that fog
cleared quickly no one notices this
obvious breathing tube bamboo balls
because no one is paying attention but
me apparently a sudden crucifixions this
apparent indigenous leader is wearing a
leopard print costume that looks like it
came from Party City these white face
Africans are so good at surprise attack
in heavily armed soldiers you think
they've been trained for it or expected
it but read the script and knew it
needed some added tension the old power
Warriors decide not to kill this man
because he is clearly Academy Award
winner Christoph Waltz ban must be an
important character in this story
Tarzan 300 that this old dude would be
this good at fighting after he hit like
a bitch during the real fight feel bad
for gemenon soo because he's almost
always cast as either the villain or the
super African guy and neither role
really does his acting ability justice
chief vaanga hive resumed wait what you
knew the name of this tribes chief but
instead of trying to open talks you just
let all your men be slaughtered how do
you know my name how do you know English
there's one thing a desire above all
else
stop billing bring him to me you shall
have your diamonds I could defeat you
and your troops easily yet I still think
you stand a better chance against Tarzan
than I do for some reason all I need is
a name cool movie moment just before the
Tarzan title screen but still you need
way more than a name dude you need a
description a location a general rundown
on skills and previous attacks did you
really have to include a little circle
our registered trademark on this movie's
title screen because if you did I'm not
sure if I'm more upset at you or u.s.
trademark law but either way it's overly
obvious and stupidest not to be confused
with London West Virginia wait there's
actually a London West Virginia well
utter fucking waste of Jim Broadbent
here's samuel l.jackson cracking walnuts
conspicuously in continuing his streak
of appearing in everything movie ever
made let me explain
the Africa situation strapped in
everyone this may take a while you are
Tarzan lord of the Apes king of the
jungle wait is this a fucking sequel why
didn't anyone tell me this changes
nothing he sent my apologies to serene
Highness movie wants me to believe
Tarzan isn't going back to Africa even
though the trailer showed me he does
indeed go back which makes this some
bull time-wasting bull right here you
can tell it's England because of how
much it's raining even in this live
action movies flashbacks
Tarzan's parents managed to build an
absolute palace in the treetops of
Africa where they crash-landed because
Tarzan's parents are Jesus level
carpenters I've done all I can to
protect them except not bring them to
Africa also the either brought an infant
a pregnant wife or knocked her up after
being stranded in the jungle none of
those are good ideas the jungle consumes
everything except English babies
obviously today I buried my Alice
I guess he bared his Alice went up to
the treehouse to write the diary entry
and came back down to grieve slash died
by gorilla
you brought your a baby on this raid the
four oh so it's not a sequel it's a
reboot masquerading as a sequel but
doing the reboot stuff in the flashbacks
brilliant yes we here Jane teaching the
kids about the power of the hippo
because later in the movie she will be
attacked by a hippopotamus how many
children would have now somehow this
movie managed to top Anakin and Padme
for insipid couples dialog any course
it's just a diplomat bring I can't take
you movie again waste time on some
bullshit we know will be overturned
shortly because the movie literally has
nothing new to offer save a few extra
courses the last thing you need is small
stress yeah and leaving her here at home
alone while you go would never cause her
any stress right hyper dicing coconuts
and playing ping-pong pretty goddamn
sure no one in the 1800's cultic
ping-pong it was table tennis or nothing
in fact I just googled it and while the
film takes place in roughly 1890 the
term ping-pong wasn't invented until the
very end of the century try to keep me
here won't work 20 minutes in in this
Tarzan movie is basically an episode of
parenthood you can take the boy out of
the jungle but you can't take the raw
egg drinking jungle technique out of the
bleep what the fuck also this movie
couldn't have happened to a more
likeable skarsgård I was happier in
Africa cliche also that's a real crisp
image for an 1880s photograph honest
question aren't there no horses how in
the ever-loving did anyone in Africa in
early 1890s managed to make this banner
just what keeping a CGI crocodile as a
pet also acting shocked by the terrain
full of ivory when you literally have a
slave holding an umbrella
you you thought the ivory trade was bad
today well no Kings payment was due
three months ago I tried that trick with
my student loans once didn't work
I feel like this happy reunion would
carry more weight if we had a first
movie telling the origin story and this
was a sequel about the return instead
this movie is trying to be both and this
reunion just feels weird we formal
enforced known as antennae until every
time and if you'd never returned we were
prepared to eternally waste this very
useful large shelter also we thought
that if you did return you'd prefer to
see it wasted away abandoned and totally
messy as as opposed to seeing eat and
tidy or having been useful to others in
your absence Anini openness you fought
to abandon bucking gala bezel do they
not always have sentries out some once
you tell them about the Lions this is
just like the ghost in the darkness only
with fewer deadly lions and more Sam
Jackson sometimes I look back on the
last few years of my life and I'm just
grateful to be doing a job where you get
to write and then narrate utterly
bonkers sentences like that one on
average a full-grown male gorilla weighs
about 350 pounds making it quite
difficult for them to use vines - Spider
Man style swing through the jungle they
would pull those vines right out of the
trees
since no man never started with less
weight what he was born in Africa his
parents died and then a magically
generous eight female took him as her
own son and raised him before we'd go on
to inherit massive wealth I'd agree the
loss of his parents is tragic but plenty
of men have started with less symbolism
aside it's literally impossible by the
laws of physics for her to be this well
lit from behind without us being able to
see anything around her in front of her
what's right here in the ruins of your
childhood home 37 minutes in still no
Tarzan II also hey you just made love in
a bed in a house no one has entered in a
decade or more exactly how much disease
do you have now I mean little feets are
toxic at this point right no way
whatever love conquers only the man who
can take on full-grown gorillas and
leopards is thwarted by a group of
regular humans Tarzan hasn't chewed
through this netting yet to go rescue
his wife he currently sees being abused
must have been something the first
moment I saw her I fell the Negras and
baboons super racist dude do you not
watch the number since oh no we're being
shot at quick let's all stand here he
tells Jane he needs her to scream she
spits on him and then he says it's no
big deal
Tarzan will come for her regardless
which makes me wonder who thought the
spitting scene was ultimately necessary
oh I'm really sad that guy's dead but
who's that guy again
I think I'm gonna barf
if you would just your eyes just what
left you in England and your castle well
yes ping yes if you've done that neither
of our two gorgeous white lead actors
would be in trouble right now
we'll be the lights in an excessive
flamingo butchery scene because movie is
a grade-a dick face amazing CGI
butterfly a hopefulness you do know that
the right side of your moustache is just
a little lower than the left this is
obviously a psychological attack on
Jane's part but damn it if she's not
right movie saves money by borrowing
b-roll from medicine man yes I did just
reference the Sean Connery disaster
medicine man is my critique less on
point because of it no it is not if we
spin the camera enough maybe Knoll
notice how CGI the ship this Tarzan
movie waits until the 50 minute mark to
even begin attempting to Tarzan magic
finds attached to nothing the snow-free
snowpiercer bullfight would be
entertaining if I could figure out why
not one of these armed soldiers even
tries firing a gun at him oh that guy
shot a gun roughly 10 seconds too late I
would take back my previous sin but I
still think it kind of stands those are
some added big earlobes you got this son
that guy's earlobes are actually quite
small and certainly not large enough to
warrant this comment which tells me no
one checked the script for accuracy
between the table read and the casting
of extras huzzah for cheap filmmaking
standards this is some poke on it right
here
guess she painted with all the colors of
the wind or something Tarzan survives
this first of all wasn't that a dream
second of all Tarzan gets beat to hell
by a gorilla then carried to a healing
building by the natives and even if this
is an extended flashback how does this
movie think it has time for the suppose
a jungle fine dining setup does not
include salt and pepper shakers no
seasoning for you my priest purchased it
for me in Jerusalem when I was nine that
sounds like you and your priests were
awfully close religious pedophilia jokes
about the Catholic Church were all the
rage in the 1890s duh would you pass the
pepper
there's no pepper on this table but
still he gets up and find some he and
prisons are just long enough to get the
pepper and then releases a wrist because
this guy is fucking with her or with us
the viewers but honestly at this point
doesn't matter I'm rooting for the Jesus
but everyone can relate to a lowborn
scrapper movie takes a great actor and
totally Hayden Christensen's him what
did Tarzan do killed his only son is
this girl even on Tarzan's side why the
she's just volunteering information to
this obvious asshat
and get ready because that is nothing
compared to what he will do to you just
kind of recently showered Lindsay Lohan
is right
Tarzan's gonna
cue up worse than Brad Pitt did yo if
you need an evil handsome man to have an
unsettlingly civilized meal with a woman
he's terrorizing Christoph Waltz's your
guy I never left a friend in trouble
or pardon in the lurch I'm not about to
start now yeah but what's in your wallet
so how you want to play this lead will
come down well fight
that's exactly how Chris and I settle
our disputes my wife just informed me
that this is a good movie now well
watching this fight makes me want to
immediately apologize to Marvel movies
for my constant ripping on their over
edited clothes of fight scenes
Jesus this is incomprehensible again how
did the modern rised on Apes movies get
Apes oh right only for all other movies
involving Apes to get the Apes so wrong
and faking this bite gets infected
you're gonna have problems because up
until now we've had no problems you
aren't going anywhere until we get this
stitched up by ants also they didn't
show his wounds being cleaned or
sterilized so the rest of this movie is
about Tarzan superpower of not dying
from certain infection eating them
tastes like bacon Oh ladies and
gentlemen comedy no one will be seated
during the elephants show up for no
reason whatsoever scene aka fantastic
beasts and how to use them to pad your
runtime not that I feel qualified to
share any kidnapping tips but why not
chained her up somewhere inside the boat
Chekhov's hippopotamuses Oh shocker
he now you cede me his way out of this
cage utterly shot I'm sorry I can't keep
this Rosa I'm not really surprised by
any of this hungry hungry hippo oh great
she's run smack into the Apes whose
leader just Cantrell Tarzan awesome
how much you want about Tarzan shows up
and saves this ballsy evil bastard walks
toward the Apes and somehow doesn't get
torn to shreds or eaten or anything that
might keep him from appearing in the
film's finale even though these same
Apes just beat the hell out of Tarzan
himself whatever movie you suck balls
promise you won't hurt them why in the
name of stupidity would you trust this
assholes promises Jesus it took less
than 15 seconds for his men to prove why
she shouldn't have trusted them and
where the stars on right now hey Tarzan
while you're listening to with dead ants
in your shoulder if you just stay put
you probably could have saved Jane by
now oh you like them apples son of actor
who was in the movie I'm quoting with
the apples thing
Tarzan may have grown up in the jungle
but there's no reason he should have
superhuman hearing also if he can hear
Jane shouldn't he be able to hear the
thousand other jungle sounds going on in
between them and here is where the
animated Disney Tarzan merges with this
supposed live-action version told you
he'd save her from this crap god I hate
being right off this no fake-ass looking
CGI Apes were actually harmed in the
making of this so-called movie during
this I just saved an ape and oh my God
look at all the dead Apes moment I'd
like to point out once again that he has
ants in his shoulder instead of stitches
I just beat your ass 15 minutes ago but
now let's be allies yes Sam Jackson's
character is still all by himself and
still not yet eaten by any of the
animals in this deadly jungle and yes
that is a random upside-down umbrella in
the shot though I actually have no
explanation for that
I guess he's covering ground already
covered by Jane and then I don't know
the umbrella is really weird this
flashback to an African tribal dude
shooting an ape is both confusing and
confusing Jai monsoon is like goddamn I
only have a few minutes of screen time
here why does all of it have to be
blurry wait I thought all that with the
arrow killing the ape was a flashback
but it wasn't and I'm just like what the
fuck is going on movie
do you even know bloodless stabbed
killings this force of hundreds that
could easily overwhelm him just stands
here watching while he beats their asses
one at a time this only happens in the
movies folks this were real Tarzan is
dead and Jane is sold to a Crypt Keeper
in Thailand Williams who is anywhere
from 40 to 70 years old and doesn't have
an army a boat a map skills an animal
training or basically any jungle
survival skills whatsoever makes it to
the final battle on his own Tarzan gets
his ass kicked again which shouldn't
happen twice in a Tarzan movie your son
kill the UNA passion I have a cat about
me oh so it was kind of a flashback at
some point there but I really stopped
caring so can we please get on with it
my son was just a boy no like you where
was your honor
John doesn't know he's in the movie so
he just keeps acting the fuck out of his
scenes once in all eyes at the planet of
the ex machina didn't he just get
speared in the kidney they literally go
from fighting these guys to instantly
talking them into joining the anti rom
calls because this movie is almost 2
hours long but still felt the need to
stretch out the boring and speed up the
interesting remember back when the
English children were fawning over a
chance to feel Tarzan's bulbous hands
that feels extra pointless right now now
that we are racing through the climax
take this row upon row of 10th base
fakeness where you going
get some friends because I was an
adopted ape once all the creatures of
Africa love and respect and follow me a
guy with a gun and a screaming gorilla
well now a herd stampeding wildebeest
because of course they will Tarzan
is running about 50 miles an hour right
now someone should show him how to fire
that gun the running of the wildebeest
1886 model Maxim machine gun father do
you know oh god damn it just and I get
this movie the quadruple bird that's
both middle fingers and both middle toes
everyone survives this ok he saved his
lady the evil men are leaving so it's
Tarzan motivated purely by revenge at
this point does he really need to kill
rom before he can find peace he does
this instead of reaching up to breaking
the line or breaking the fucking boat
Tarzan is strong and almost a superhero
but he's dumber than a box of rocks yeah
I could do that
my neck is that strong I just waited a
while to do it to build suspense at
least six Crocs feeding on ROM and yet
still no blood that's weird right movie
once you to think Tarzan was still on
the ship when it blew up but this is a
movie mere moments from the end so if
you have half a brain you're just
annoyed by this bull stalling tactic
what did I tell you huh this is
paint-by-numbers moviemaking folks have
you ever seen a movie before even just
one then you could have made this movie
we have witnesses documents letters and
official record and enslavement of the
Congolese peep and the king of Belgium
agreed with the open letter and no
atrocities happened to the Congolese
people ever again it's pretty much never
a good sign when a movie that is 10
minutes from ending including credits
gives you a one year later title card
it's the very definition of not
necessary ah they're doing they're
having a baby dance Jane had a baby and
that was totally worth attacked on one
year later Bulls right
that guy hasn't done anything yet you
get on gonna do something and you know
it's gonna be good
these will you came for this is what you
came for
I pray that someone will save you
[Music]
Joey Potter I like you don't be like him
nothing stops this drink where I out
here